naohia read a book cover to cover in a
single session at a rate of 55 pages per
hour 55 pages per hour
after reading for four hours after
reading for four hours he had 330 pages
left to read how long is the book and
pages and how long did it take naoh to
read the entire book
well there's a bunch of ways that we
could approach this and like always
pause the video and try to figure it out
but i will go with one way first and
then maybe i'll tackle it in another way
so one way is let's just set up a little
table here
and on one column
let's think about let's think about how
long naolia has read
in hours so we'll just call that time t
for time in hours this is how long he
has read and in this column this is how
much he has left to read so let's just
write that l
left to read and then this is going to
be given in pages
this is going to be given in pages
so let's see we don't know at zero hours
we don't know how many pages he has left
to read at if we knew that that's gonna
at zero hours before he's read that the
page is left to read that's going to be
the entire book so that's that would
answer this question how long is the
book so this is going to be interesting
we don't know what happens at one hour
after three two hours after three hours
but they do tell us that after reading
for four hours after reading for four
hours he had 330 pages left to read
so after four hours he had
330 pages
330 pages left to read
so based on this
and the fact that he's reading at 55
pages per hour can we back up to figure
out all of this
well remember every hour that goes by
every hour that goes by he has read 55
pages
so if he's read 55 pages remember this
330 this isn't how many pages he's read
this is how many he has left to read so
after every hour he has 55 fewer pages
to read so at 3 hours he should have 55
more pages to read so this should be at
3 hours 330 plus 55 would be
385 and let's see whether this makes
sense so when our change in time this
triangle is just the greek letter delta
means change in when our change in time
is plus one plus one hour
our change in pages left to read is
going to be equal to
negative 55
pages and that makes sense the pages
left to read goes down every hour this
is we're measuring not how much he's
read we're measuring how much he has
left to read so that should go down by
55 pages every hour or if we were to go
backwards through time it should go up
so two hours he should have 55 more
pages to read so what's 380 what's 385
plus 55 we'll see 385 plus 5 is 390 plus
is 440. so we'd have 440 pages and all i
did is i added 55
and then after reading for one hour he
would have 55 more pages than after
reading for two hours so 440 plus 55 is
495.
and then before he started reading or
right when he started reading he would
have had to read even 55 more pages
because after one hour he would have
read those 55 pages so 495 plus 55
is going to be let's see it's gonna be
add five you get to 500 plus another 50
is 550 pages
so time equals zero he had 550 pages to
read
so that's how long the book is
but how long does it take naoh to read
the entire book
well we could keep going we could say
okay at the fifth hour this thing's
going to go down by 55 so let's see if
this goes down by 50 if this goes down
by 50
we're going to get to 280 but then you
go down five more it's going to go to
and we could keep going on and on and on
or we could just say look he's got 330
pages left to read and he's going to
this let me write this let me write the
units down two pages and he's reading at
a rate of 55
pages per hour
pages per
hour this is the same thing this is
going to be equal to 330
pages
times 1
over 55
hours
per page
i'm dividing by something the same thing
as multiplying by its reciprocal so 55
pages per hours if you divide by that
that's the same thing as multiplying by
1 55th of an hour per page is one way to
think about it and so what you get the
pages cancel out pages divided by pages
and you have 330 divided by 55 hours
divided by 55
hours
and what's that going to be let's see 30
divided by 5 is 6 300 divided by 50 is
6. so this is going to be equal to 6
hours now we have to be very careful you
might want to write 6 hours here but
this is 6 hours after this point 6 hours
after that point so in total it's going
to take him 10 hours at 4 hours you have
330 pages left to read and then there's
six more hours to finish those 330 pages
so it's going to take a total of 10
hours and we can also see if this makes
sense if he reads 55 if he reads 550
pages in 10 hours
if he reads 550 pages
in 10 hours in 10 hours what's his rate
of reading
well if 550 divided by 10 that's going
to be the same thing as 55
pages
per hour which is consistent with what
we just read that he reads at 55 pages
per hour
now another way that you could have
tackled this you could say hey this is
going to be a linear equation
is if you're well versed with your
linear equations you could say look he's
reading at a constant rate and if we're
talking about let's say let me just set
up a function here we could say left to
read as a function of time
is going to be equal to he's reading at
a rate of 55 pages per hour so the
amount he's left to read is going to go
down by 55 pages per hour so it's going
to go down
55 pages every hour so you could write
it like that
plus
whatever the initial number of pages
were plus whatever the initial number of
pages were and then you could use this
information right over here to solve for
b
we know that when time is equal to four
hours we know that when let me do that
color
we know that when time is equal to 4
hours
that the pages left to read are 330
pages left to read are 330 and so you
get 330 is equal to
let's see negative 55 times 4 is
negative 220
negative 2
plus
negative 220 plus b
plus b
and then if you add 220 to both sides
220 add 220 to both sides
you're going to be left with on this
side you're going to get 550
is equal to these cancel out they add up
to 0 is equal to b and so the function
that describes how much he has left to
read the amount he has left to read as a
function of time
is well he's reading 55 pages per hour
so the amount he has left or is going to
go down every hour that's why we have
that negative there
so negative 5 negative 55 pages per hour
times the number of hours
plus 550.
so if someone said well how long is the
book well that's that's going to be l of
zero that's going to be how many pages
he has left to read at time zero and we
see that l of 0 is going to be 550. when
t is equal to 0 let me write this down l
of 0 is going to be equal to
550 when t is equal to 0 this term goes
away and you just have 550 pages and
just like that
we could have answered
this question
and then you could say well look if the
book is 550 pages and if he's reading at
55 pages per hour how many hours is
going to take well 550 pages divided by
55 pages per hour is going to get you 10
hours and we could have done that here
actually now that i think about it
instead of saying 330 pages divided by
55 pages per hour and say hey that's
going to take us six more hours from
this point we already knew this and we
could have said look if we have 550
pages to read and we're reading at 55
pages per hour it's going to take us 10
hours so you see there's a ton of
different ways to solve these problems
and they're all really at the end of the
day representing the same thing that's
what's neat about mathematics
they're just ways of of representing
wait thing how to think about things and
at the end of the day we're really just
thinking about the same problem just
representing it with with different ways
and different symbols